hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the body now this game
was made by the same developer of one
chance and if you remember that game it
was a flash game where you only had a
single chance to save the entire world
admittedly from your own mistake but if
you want to see that game you can check
in the description below but this one I
actually found and not a lot of people
have played it and it seemed to be from
his description another emotional game
and I wanted to give it a try because
when I opened up it seemed very bizarre
in that it's presented in this real whoa
oh no my character was my character was
just holding a body bag in it oh oh no
oh no oh no oh no my body
Oh
well that took a turn real quick it's
amazing how something so some space for
me to use oh no is that a shovel Oh God
okay let's leave that right there
there we go gotta be in the right spot
for it I've gotta keep digging with the
spacebar gotta be good about it oh hi oh
no oh no oh no oh come on why you gotta
make me do this my character is still in
black and white apparently oh no oh what
happened so I want to know what happened
hi
is the game waiting for me to do
something because I don't think I want
to do it what's gonna happen when I
press the spacebar oh oh what what did I
kill that guy I'm assuming that's what
happened oh god I can't even go that way
what the hell oh my god okay I guess I'm
running now I suppose I don't even know
how the police would have gotten here I
mean at all my god what is this some
sort of symbolism about me running away
from the police and running away from my
own crimes so who's that lady and who is
that guy that just came is this even
real is the big question that I'm saying
here and that's a cabin and I saw this
as a painting in the house I was just in
if you look closely this okay
oh [ __ ]
wow that was a sudden jarring change
oh wow that's it chills down my spine
arrow keys to aim
Oh No
oh my god that's over so quickly I think
he shot himself hang on I gotta go back
and I gotta see if there's something
else I could have done there oh man that
like I didn't even have a chance to
realize what was happening like I was
trying to comprehend it while who was
going under I don't know let me get the
back to that point again and then I can
actually think rationally this must be
this must be a bunch of bodies that are
buried over time if I'm supposed to
interpret this I would assume that this
is all very symbolic and this is like an
accelerated concept that we're supposed
to understand this isn't taking place in
immediate reality here this is like man
that transition right there is jarring
as hell so what happens if I go to the
right man that's so weird like just the
option to shoot yourself right then and
there and then there's no fanfare to it
it's just what does that mean what does
that mean oh man is there something I
gotta find out if there's something else
do it I had a fire I gotta find out I a
lot of different things I couldn't find
anything else there's no other way to go
in the house there was no other way to
go pretty much anywhere that I went so
there's gotta be something else before
maybe if I leave the church as soon as I
get in there
and I'll wrap up my thoughts in a second
about what this is but I got to get
through this first so I couldn't do
anything in the church maybe if I
okay um okay I don't hang on I got a
double check to make sure they let me
check like a walkthrough with um Dan
I'll be right back okay so I looked it
up and there's a total of three
different endings there is one which is
shooting yourself and then oddly enough
that's the only one where you get to see
who can I can only assume as your wife
again and then you can take the shotgun
and you can go outside I'm assuming to
fight or you can just go outside and I'm
assuming surrender yourself to the
police this is a bizarre short and oddly
emotional game like it hits various it's
very astonishing how much it can affect
you in such a short amount of time like
just within the beginning when you pass
by that tree and suddenly it turns into
a woman that changes everything about it
because you could be a hitman that's
trying to bury his last body but as soon
as it turns into that woman is like whoa
that took a 180 really quickly and then
who was the guy that came over there and
then gone the ground and I obviously
murdered him then I was having weird
flashbacks and then you go into the
shack and it's a church and yeah yeah
you're marrying you go back to the dead
to be mayor and then that's sudden like
that immediate cut shift to just
blackness with the shotgun in a shack by
yourself that is that is like heavy [ __ ]
but it's amazing it always amazes me how
much people people can pack into such a
small package so I I might be wrong
about lavas but I think the guy whose
wife was either murdered or died and
this guy was trying to seek revenge and
all those body bags were the bodies he
buried in revenge for the death of his
wife and I'm not a hundred percent sure
on that because the guy that comes in
and then falls to the ground I don't
know who he is in relation to everybody
else but maybe you guys have a better
idea of it I'd like to know what you
think and come
bloom thank you everybody so much for
watching and if you got other cool games
like this I really am interested in
games like this because it just goes to
show what can be presented in a game so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
you